looking for the zack attack here tonight
just did not have it from the get go
last week at wrigley field
and the thing that makes it especially
frustrating about zach allen if you've
looked at the diamondbacks pitching
staff he probably has the best pure
stuff of anybody that they'll send out
there to the mound sure but yet he
doesn't seem to have confidence every
start to go out there and attack the
strike zone with that good stuff
[Applause]
called strike three of fastball appeared
to be outside jerry davis rings up
taylor
and that's one away
[Applause]
right down the middle turner takes it
two out
hear the reception from an always very
pro dodger crowd in phoenix welcoming
back corey seeger for his first game
since may 15. 2-1
bouncing ball to second
off for van meter and the inning
continues
so an air on josh van meter among other
things the diamondbacks are the worst
defensive team in baseball this year and
mater popped up to lead it off for the
diamondbacks
ace is loaded in two
outs pull down the line fairball here we
go
kelly is home peralta is home they're
going to stop varsha with third josh van
mater makes it two-nothing diamondbacks
and atlanta tonight losing or winning uh
should say nine to five over the braves
and there's the strikeout for gallon
that's his fourth
[Applause]
furball that time three consecutive
strikeouts for gallon and now five in
the ball game you know i say with a
hitter sometimes all it takes is one
line drive to find your swing maybe it's
one curve ball from zach gallon and
he'll find that pitch this is a
beautiful curve
dropped right out there at the outside
corner at the knees chance to strike out
the side in the third
call strike three gallon strikes out the
side he got taylor muncie and turner
and he holds a two-nothing lead
home with another 002 to strikeout
varsity
one go on in the fourth
[Applause]
squares again
bounce through it
two out
[Applause]
amen on the move will smith the throw
he's in there
seventh stolen base of the year for nick
take a look what new york thinks
he's safe
what are you laughing at it looked like
one of the umpires i couldn't see what
it was stuck his tongue out at dave
roberts before the signal is safe you
say what is this kindergarten what do
you mean he stuck his tongue out
i promise you watch greg gibbs on the
left stick
what is this kindergarten i got it right
in live action
[Music]
some of the relationships between
managers players and certain umpires
that have that kind of well-rounded
personality is so much fun
as drooble pokes it out there and it
gets into center
ahmed will score van meters in at third
and it's three nothing diamond downs
they roll him out at third van meter
wants a challenge toribello wants to
take a look he's safe
and he is safe the wind up and the pitch
swing and a miss
got him with a fastball down bellinger
didn't get it and that's strikeout
number seven now for gallaudet taylor's
so important for this team leads off
this sixth and lifts the fly ball to
left center field way back there and
gone in the first pitch of the inning
taylor gets the dodgers on the board
with his 17th home run of the year
a no doubter for taylor
it's his sixth home run
in his last 10 games gonna stick with
gallon for will smith though for two
he's flying out to center twice
[Applause]
yes he win rob drake rings him up
gallon gets the strikeout that's his
eighth
one gone base is still loaded pollock
against his old squad drives one in the
air to deep right center field it is
verso to catch it on the track
in comes muncie and it's 3-2 and gallons
survive this with the lead bellinger
over two
hopped it up
behind shortstop cabrera calling for it
peralta comes in and collects it
and gallon will survive with the lead
drew ellis steps in to batten making his
major league debut
hey drew ellis has got a knock in his
first big league at back welcome to the
big leagues there it is
a base hit 102 off the bat first at bat
for drew ellis in the big league yeah
congratulations to drew ellis first of
many alex vasila acquired in a trade
with the marlins this spring
faces josh van mader van mader sends it
to right center and ellis is on the move
tony paris chica going to send him home
here's the throw he's in there
second rbi double tonight for josh van
meter and they get a run right back 1-1
in the air deep to center
bellinger's on the track van meters
coming home rbi for walker and make it
5-2
mounted
central rally got the time running to
the plate chris taylor hits one in the
air to right center field indeed back
goes varsity over his head short hops
the wall
right on the heels of mckinney is baity
throw goes to third tanner's got a
triple it's a one-run game chris taylor
again igniting the dodgers
miguel aguilar thrown right into the
deep end of the pool and his major
league debut
aguilar strikes out his first big league
hitter it's max muncie way to go
oh it's a good night so far for big
league debuts and aguilars here are the
big leagues ground ball to second van
meter how about this miguel aguilar
welcome to the big leagues what a job
off of the bench trying to get him over
the hump
pujol slides a base head into center
time run is in it's 5-5 as pujols drives
in another
5-5 bottom of the eighth
two out bases loaded
3-2 pitch
hey struck him out
climb the ladder with the cutter
jensen gets out of the jam
as drooble had an rbi single in the
fourth he's walked three times
as drooble trying to drop it into left
it gets down here comes marshall here's
the throw diamondbacks win it